This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The other day, the writer Anne Helen Peterson was watching Martin Scorsese's 1993 film, The Age of Innocence. First of all, The Age of Innocence is low key my favorite Scorsese, which is blasphemy, but I just love the movie a lot. That is a bold choice, Anne Helen Peterson, and I am here for it. If you don't people are always like, oh, but all of his films are so violent, and the Age of Innocence is an emotionally violent movie. So it's just operating in a different register. It's the blind, I love it so much. The Age of Innocence looks really different from any of Scorsese's other films. It's not set in some gritty criminal underworld, it doesn't have
这里是《99%无形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。前几天，作家安妮·海伦·彼得森正在看马丁·斯科塞斯1993年的电影《纯真年代》。首先，《纯真年代》低调地成为我最喜欢的斯科塞斯电影，虽然这有点离经叛道，但我就是非常喜欢这部电影。这是一个大胆的选择，安妮·海伦·彼得森，我举双手赞成。如果你不，人们总是会说，哦，但是他的所有电影都那么暴力，而《纯真年代》是一部情感暴力的电影。所以它只是在不同的频道上运作。它是盲目的，我太喜欢它了。《纯真年代》看起来与斯科塞斯的任何其他电影都真的非常不同。它不是以某个残酷的犯罪地下世界为背景，它没有
Robert De Niro in it. It looks almost like a merchant ivory film, a gilded age costume drama, set in New York. It's the kind of film that you watch to get lost in the rose gardens, in the frilly dresses, in the wallpaper drawing rooms. But on this particular rewatch, and noticed something else about the set design that really stood out, the houses were packed to the gills with plants. I was so fascinated by just how prevalent houseplants were throughout the entire film, and actually sort of as an really important
罗伯特·德尼罗在里面。它看起来几乎像一部梅里尔·伊沃里的电影，一部镀金时代的服装剧，以纽约为背景。这是那种你看完后会迷失在玫瑰园、褶边连衣裙、壁纸会客室里的电影。但在这次特别的重看中，我注意到了布景设计的另一处真正引人注目的地方：房子里塞满了植物。我深深着迷于室内植物在整部电影中是多么无处不在，实际上它某种程度上作为几个关键场景的非常重要的
backdrop for several pivotal scenes. Throughout the movie, the characters wander between giant ferns and palms. The kinds of plants that you might find in a swankey buti-co-tail today. In fact, when I see the plants in the age of innocence, they look almost inachronistic to me. Like, you can imagine the production designer buying them at lows. Well, I think oftentimes people don't think that anyone other than us had houseplants somehow, right? There's just this assumption that somehow houseplants are a creation of contemporary society, contemporary decorating, you know, like something that is as new as IKEA say.
背景。在整部电影中，角色们在巨大的蕨类植物和棕榈树之间漫步。这种你在如今时髦的时髦鸡尾酒会可能会看到的植物。事实上，当我看到《纯真年代》中的植物时，我觉得它们对我来说几乎是不合时宜的。就像，你能想象制片设计师在劳氏购买它们一样。好吧，我想人们往往认为除了我们之外，不知怎的没有人拥有室内植物，对吧？这里有一种假设，即不知怎的，室内植物是当代社会、当代装饰的产物，你知道的，就像像宜家一样新的东西。
And I mean, it's true that houseplants are having a moment right now. In 2020, 66% of people in the US owned at least one houseplant, and plant cells have skyrocketed during the pandemic. Meanwhile, Instagram accounts like Houseplant Club have over a million followers. And over the past decade, there's been a steady stream of think pieces offering explanations for the emergence of this new obsession from the rise of wellness culture
我的意思是，室内植物现在确实很受欢迎，这是真的。2020年，美国66%的人至少拥有一盆室内植物，而且大流行期间植物销量飙升。与此同时，像 Houseplant Club 这样的 Instagram 账号拥有超过一百万的粉丝。在过去十年中，出现了一连串的深度文章，为这种新痴迷的出现提供了解释，从健康文化的兴起
to the fact that more young people are living in cities. But one thing that these articles don't usually do is put our current houseplant bloom in historical perspective. Because while millennials may have perfected the art of plant parenting, and is here to tell you this is not the first time people have gotten completely obsessed with houseplants. There's so much history packed into this unassuming artifact that's in your home. And so I had been thinking a little bit about what could that history be.
到越来越多的年轻人住在城市这一事实。但这些文章通常没有做的一件事，是将我们当前的室内植物热潮置于历史视角中。因为虽然千禧一代可能已经完善了植物养育的艺术，但安妮在这里告诉你，这并不是人们第一次对室内植物彻底着迷。你家里的这个不起眼的物件里包含了如此多的历史。因此，我一直在思考这种历史可能是什么。
If you think about it, the entire idea of the house plant is pretty bizarre. We take plants that grow naturally in one place and then we move them halfway around the world to an entirely different place with a different, often inhospitable climate. And then we keep them alive by growing them in potting soil that we probably bought at the Home Depot. Which raises a lot of questions like for one why, we'll get to that later, but also when, as in, when did we start engaging in this weird ritual? Humans have been growing plants indoors for a long time,
如果你想想看，室内植物整个这个概念是相当怪异的。我们把在一个地方自然生长的植物，然后把它们搬到世界半球的另一个地方，搬到一个气候完全不同、通常并不适合生存的环境中。然后我们通过在可能从全美家居建材店买来的盆栽土里种植它们，来让它们保持生命。这就引发了很多问题，比如为什么，我们稍后会讲到，但还有什么时候，也就是，我们是什么时候开始参与这个奇怪的仪式的？人类在室内种植植物已经很久了，
especially herbs and flowers. Ancient Egyptian, Greek, and Middle Eastern societies all had potted plants. The Chinese were growing ornamental plants indoors as far back as 1,000 BC. But the rise of the global house plant economy that we are familiar with today really begins during the age of European imperialism.
尤其是草药和花卉。古埃及、希腊和中东社会都有盆栽植物。早在公元前1000年，中国就已经在室内种植观赏植物了。但我们今天熟悉的全球室内植物经济的兴起，真正始于欧洲帝国主义时代。
I mean, they really began with the start of colonization. So you have these powers in Europe who are going out to the corners of colonization. So you have these powers in Europe who are going out to the corners of the known world and encountering so many new Flora and Fauna. Also, of course, people, but for the purposes of this story, we're going to stay focused on the planets. This was the Enlightenment era,
我的意思是，它们确实随着殖民主义的开始而开始。所以你有这些欧洲列强，他们前往已知世界的各个角落，遇到了如此多的新植物和动物。当然还有人，但为了这个故事的目的，我们将继续把重点放在植物上。这是启蒙时代，
and European scientists were obsessed with cataloging and collecting all of the new species that they encountered. And so, on many of these expeditions, they would actually bring along people whose entire job was to hunt for plants. Here's interior design historian Penny Spark and Kingston University in London. The plant hunters themselves were sort of intrepid people, often by the scientists or by the kings or by the very wealthy who wanted plants brought back. They just went and hunted out in the wild and you know up mountains, into forests, into jungles, bringing back everything they could and more exotic, the better. They put them in boxes and transported them over many months long voyages back to the cold
欧洲科学家痴迷于编目和收集他们遇到的所有新物种。因此，在许多这些探险中，他们实际上会带上那些全部工作就是寻找植物的人。这是伦敦金斯顿大学的室内设计历史学家佩妮·斯帕克斯。植物猎人本身就是一些勇敢的人，通常由科学家、国王或非常富有想要植物被带回来的人资助。他们只是去野外狩猎，你知道的，上山，进森林，进丛林，尽可能多地带回所有东西，而且越奇异越好。他们把它们装进箱子里，经过长达数月的航行，把它们运回寒冷的
climate of Europe. But the transportation part proved to be a bit of a challenge. Unsurprisingly, the plants didn't do so well on ships floating in the ocean for weeks at a time. And they would just die on the way, always. People in this period believe that plants needed fresh air to survive, but on a sea voyage, they ended up just dying from exposure to the elements. By one estimate, only one in 1,000 live plant specimens would survive the journey back to Europe. And so there were sorts of experiments we had to take into trying find ways of preserving the plants.
欧洲气候。但运输部分被证明是一个不小的挑战。毫不奇怪，植物在漂浮在海洋中数周的船只上表现并不是很好。它们会在途中死去，总是这样。这一时期的认为植物需要新鲜空气才能生存，但在海上航行中，它们最终只是死于风吹雨打。据估计，每1000个活植物标本中，只有1个能活着回到欧洲。因此，我们不得不进行各种实验，试图寻找保存植物的方法。
And one of the most successful was something called a Bordian case designed by somebody called the Sanul Ward. The Bordian case was like a small portable greenhouse. The plants were sealed off from the outside world and got their water to the cycle of evaporation and condensation. It was in closed case that actually allowed moist just to go back into the plant and keep it alive. And essentially what it did was create this moist environment inside that approximated a jungle.
其中最成功的一种被称为沃德箱，由一个叫纳撒尼尔·沃德的人设计。沃德箱就像一个小型便携式温室。植物与外界隔绝，通过蒸发和冷凝的循环获得水分。这是一个封闭的箱子，实际上允许湿气回到植物体内并保持其生命。本质上它所做的是在内部创造了这个近似丛林的潮湿环境。
In 1833, two wardeen cases were sent to Australia, and they returned a year later full of plants. Ward wrote, these plants were not once watered during the whole voyage, yet on their arrival at the docks, they were in the most healthy and vigorous condition. From that point on, the Warty encase became a key tool for colonial plant traders, but keeping the plants alive once they got back to Europe also proved to be a challenge. They were evolved to grow in steamy jungles and parched deserts. They weren't going to thrive in cold rainy countries like England or France on their own. And so European gardeners needed to build indoor spaces that would approximate the climates
1833年，两个沃德箱被送到澳大利亚，一年后它们满载植物归来。沃德写道，这些植物在整个航程中没有浇过一次水，然而当它们到达码头时，它们处于最健康和旺盛的状态。从那时起，沃德箱成为殖民地植物商人的关键工具，但让植物回到欧洲后保持活力也被证明是一个挑战。它们进化成在闷热的丛林和干旱的沙漠中生长。它们无法靠自己英国或法国这样寒冷多雨的国家茁壮成长。因此，欧洲园丁需要建造室内空间，以近似
of India, Australia, and the Caribbean. And so they created botanical gardens all over Europe, and some parts of them were private and used for more scientific purposes, and some parts of them were public and open to anyone who could browse this array, this demonstration of empire and of conquest in a very secure and safe environment. The plants were called exotics and the European public flocked to botanical gardens to marvel at all of these strange new species that they had never seen before. I think about a palm arriving. If all you've ever experienced really in terms of trees is deciduous trees and evergreen
印度、澳大利亚和加勒比海的气候。因此，他们在整个欧洲建造了植物园，其中一部分是私人的，用于更多的科学目的，而一部分是公众的，对任何能够在这个展示、帝国和征服的展示中在一个非常安全和安心的环境中浏览的人开放。这些植物被称为外来植物，欧洲公众蜂拥至植物园，惊叹于他们从未见过的所有这些奇怪的新物种。我想象一棵棕榈树的到来。如果你所经历的树木方面的全部其实只有落叶树和常绿
trees, you have a palm. Like, what is this? How does it live? Botanical gardens also provided an opportunity for Europeans to see what the natural world might have looked like in the colonies. They were almost like imperial theme parks, and growing these tropical plants in Europe was a demonstration of conquest and control. And so what you do with these wild plants, even just the idea of calling them wild, right, and exotic, you bring them back and you civilize them.
树，你有一棵棕榈树。就像，这是什么？它是怎么生活的？植物园还为欧洲人提供了一个机会，让他们看看殖民地自然世界可能是什么样子。它们几乎就像帝国主题公园，在欧洲种植这些热带植物是对征服和控制的展示。所以你对这些野生植物做什么，甚至只是称它们为野生的和外来的这个想法，对吧，你把它们带回来并使它们文明化。
You put them in a pot, and then you keep them indoors. Public botanical gardens were many house plants first step in their journey out of the jungle. The next step brought them closer to the home itself. The European aristocracy grew so enchanted with tropical exotics that they wanted greenhouse as of their own, so they started building conservatories on their estates. And as indoor plants became fashionable status symbols, the desire to have your very own conservatory filtered down to the middle classes. Then in the middle of the 19th century, England got rid of a really high tax on glass.
你把它们放在一个盆里，然后把它们放在室内。公共植物园是许多室内植物走出丛林之旅的第一步。下一步使它们更接近住宅本身。欧洲贵族对热带外来植物如此着迷，以至于他们想要自己的温室，于是他们开始在他们的庄园上建造暖房。随着室内植物成为时尚的状态象征，拥有自己专属暖房的渴望渗入了中产阶级。然后在19世纪中叶，英国取消了一项针对玻璃的非常高的税。
And that made conservatories available to a much wider swath of the population. So, whereas the wealthiest states, country estates, would have greenhouses and conservatories on the land, middle-class suburban home would want its own little conservatory. And increasingly, these conservatars were attached to houses. They weren't situated at the greenhouse at the back of the gov, and they were actually attached. This was all happening at the dawn of urbanization and industrialization in Europe, as lots of people moved off the land and into the city for the very first time.
这使得暖房能够被更广泛的人群所使用。因此，尽管最富有的庄园、乡间庄园会在土地上拥有温室和暖房，但中产阶级的郊区住宅也会想要它自己的小暖房。而且这些暖房越来越多地与房屋相连。它们没有建在政府后方的温室里，而是实际相连的。这一切都发生在欧洲城市化和工业化的初期，当时许多人第一次离开土地进入城市。
And that was the first moment, really, I think, where a generation of people had left the land and left living within nature and gone into the urban setting. They realized something was missing. So they had a huge loss, sense of loss. And these conservatories were a way to try to deal with that loss and bring nature back into people's lives. On a traditional country estate,
而那真的是第一个时刻，我认为，一整代人离开了土地，离开了在大自然中的生活，进入了城市环境。他们意识到有什么东西不见了。所以他们有了巨大的失落感。而这些暖房是试图应对这种失落感并将自然带回人们生活中的一种方式。在一个传统的乡间庄园里，
the Gardiner would have been a man, but in the city indoor plant care fell to women. This was happening at the same time as the rise of separate spheres ideology. Men were expected to go out into the city and work. And the woman is the person left at home to do nurturing of children and but also of plants. Victorian women shared scientific knowledge and plant care tips in these advice books that circulated widely at the time. The writers of these books were almost like the Instagram plant influencers of their day. They would teach people the scientific names of plants how often to water them, how to
园丁通常是一个男人，但在城市里，室内植物的照料落在了女性身上。这发生在分开领域意识形态兴起的同一时期。人们期望男人走出去到城市里工作。而女人是留在家里抚养孩子以及照料植物的人。维多利亚时代的女性在当时广为流传的这些建议书中分享了科学知识和植物照料技巧。这些书的作者几乎就像他们那个时代的 Instagram 植物网红。他们会教人们植物的学名、多久浇一次水、如何
make sure they got enough light. Indoor plants got more and more popular in this period until they eventually outgrew the conservatory and moved inside the house. Yes, it is, it's a gradual infiltration of the home. Again, the advice books will tell you there's ways in which you can actually bring plants into your drawing room, your parlour. You can construct so many containers
确保它们获得充足的光线。室内植物在这段时期越来越受欢迎，直到它们最终超越了暖房并搬进了房屋内部。是的，它是，它是对住宅的逐渐渗透。同样，建议书会告诉你，有几种方法你可以实际上把植物带到你的会客厅、起居室。你可以建造这么多的容器
or shelving systems or window boxes, hanging baskets. There was a whole industry of containers really. The Victorian period was a high watermark for houseplants and they became essential components of interior design. In the Victorian period they became incredibly important elements of the interior scheme, if you like, the interior decor. The Victorians famously had and everything but the kitchen sink approach to interior design. There's a phrase I love that sometimes used to describe the aesthetics from this period.
或货架系统或窗台花箱、吊篮。真的有一个完整的容器产业。维多利亚时代是室内植物的最高水位线，它们成为室内设计必不可少的组成部分。在维多利亚时代，如果你愿意的话，它们成为室内方案、室内装饰中极其重要的元素。维多利亚时代的人以拥有几乎包罗万象的室内设计方法而闻名。我喜欢的一个短语有时用来描述这一时期的美学。
Horror Vacuay, which means the fear of empty space. You know, we use the word clutter a lot about these engineers. I don't like things that are being cluttered. I think they were just very, very full, full of furniture, full of date decorations, full of plants, full of everything. Victorians brought the unruly jungle inside and filled up their homes with many of the same varieties of houseplants that we have today. The fern was incredibly popular, and of course the palms.
恐怖真空，这意味着对空旷空间的恐惧。你知道，我们对这些工程师经常使用杂乱这个词。我不喜欢杂乱无章的东西。我认为它们只是非常非常满，满是家具，满是日期装饰，满是植物，满是所有东西。维多利亚时代的人把难以驾驭的丛林带到室内，并用我们今天拥有的许多相同品种的室内植物填满了他们的家。蕨类植物非常受欢迎，当然还有棕榈树。
So the palm and the fern were perhaps the two dominant ones, and the fern was the poor man's palm, really, because palms were exotic and very expensive. Ferns could be found indigently. Ferns were sometimes grown in the fireplace during the summer months. Ivees were draped across walls, over doorways and around window frames, and the Victorian's even designed furniture for their plants. One example was a palm table, in which you would have a hole in the set. This would be a large dining table.
所以棕榈树和蕨类植物也许是两个占主导地位的，而蕨类植物真的是穷人的棕榈树，因为棕榈树具有异国情调且非常昂贵。蕨类植物可以在本土找到。蕨类植物有时在夏季存放在壁炉里。常春藤被挂在墙上、门廊上和窗框周围，维多利亚时代的人甚至为他们的植物设计家具。一个例子是一张棕榈桌，其中在中央有一个洞。这将是一张大型餐桌。
There would be a hole in the middle and when the plant pot would be on the floor, beneath the hole, with the fronds of the leaves coming up through the hole. So it's as if it's sprouting from the table. All of this meant that Victorians had a remarkably intimate relationship with their plants. Penny Spark read a lot of these advice books for her research, and she noticed that people talked about their plants very lovingly, almost like they were sentient. A lot was written about the role of plants as being not just decorative, but also almost being like human beings. They were seen as companions, particularly to lonely people or bereaved people.
中间会有一个洞，当花盆放在洞下方的地板上时，叶子的叶柄会从洞里长出来。所以就好像它从桌子上长出来一样。所有这一切意味着维多利亚时代的人与他们的植物有着非常亲密的关系。佩妮·斯帕克斯在她的研究中阅读了许多这些建议书，她注意到人们带着极大的爱意谈论他们的植物，几乎就像它们是有知觉的一样。有很多关于植物角色的文章，不仅具有装饰性，而且几乎就像人类一样。它们被视为伴侣，特别是对孤独的人或痛失亲人的人来说。
They were seen to actually be almost substitute human beings, but like I suppose pets. I recently saw a tweet that said, plants are the new pets and pets are the new kids, which, yeah, that's a good tweet, it's funny, it rings true. But I don't know how new any of it is. I actually think the Victorians were the first plant parents. The Victorian houseplant mania lasted into the early 20th century, but like all trends,
它们实际上几乎被视为人类的替代品，但我想就像宠物一样。我最近看到一条推文说，植物是新宠物，宠物是新孩子，这，是的，这是一条好推文，它很有趣，它听起来很真实。但我不知道其中有多少是新的。我实际上认为维多利亚时代的人是第一代植物父母。维多利亚时代的室内植物狂热持续到了20世纪初，但像所有趋势一样，
it eventually cycled at a fashion. The way that I think of houseplants now is in waves, almost because I think a wave is a great way to think of growing in popularity and then ebbing in popularity, but still there, like the water still there, because houseplants never entirely disappear. But they came pretty close in the early 20th century with the dawn of modernism. The reason we have a term like modernism to describe so many different types of art and design, whether it's the writing of Hemingway
它最终淡出了时尚。我现在看待室内植物的方式是一波一波的，几乎是因为我认为波浪是思考人气增长然后人气回落的好方法，但它仍然在那里，就像水仍然在那里一样，因为室内植物从未完全消失。但在20世纪初随着现代主义的黎明，它们非常接近消失。我们之所以有一个像现代主义这样的词来描述如此多不同类型的艺术和设计，无论是海明威的写作
or the design of these homes, is because they do share these characteristics of a rejection of that older way of doing things. And just as Hemingway famously rejected the ornate language of Victorian-era novelists, modernist designers rejected the busy interiors of the Victorian home, which they described as overly domestic and feminine.
还是这些房屋的设计，是因为它们确实具有对旧做事方式的拒绝的这些特征。正如海明威以拒绝维多利亚时代小说家的华丽语言而闻名一样，现代主义设计师拒绝了维多利亚时代住宅繁杂的室内装潢，他们将其描述为过度家庭化和女性化。
No more horror, vacu-y. The modernists were all about the vacu-y. The modernists, they're saying, we want. The modernists are saying we want open spaces. We want integration with the outdoor world. We want very few decorations at all. And that meant very few houseplants. So I think on the face of it at least, the house plant is really thrown out
不再有恐怖真空。现代主义者全神贯注于真空。现代主义者，他们在说，我们想要。现代主义者在说我们想要开阔的空间。我们希望与室外世界融合。我们根本不希望有太多的装饰。这意味着很少的室内植物。所以我想至少表面上看来，室内植物确实被现代主义者
with domesticity by the modernist. It's seen as something belonging to an era they want to move away from. But at the same time, the house plants hang on in there. The modernists didn't get rid of house plants altogether, but they didn't want palms sprouting out of tables or ferns growing in the fireplace. In the perfect modernist home, everything was very spare. You just had a few pieces of simple furniture, maybe one painting on the wall. And if we do have houseplants, it's going to be like one sculptural houseplant in the corner,
连同家政一起抛弃了。它被视为属于他们想要抛弃的时代的东西。但与此同时，室内植物坚持了下来。现代主义者并没有完全摆脱室内植物，但他们不希望棕榈树从桌子上冒出来，或者蕨类植物在壁炉里生长。在完美的现代主义住宅中，一切都非常简朴。你只有几件简单的家具，墙上可能有一幅画。如果我们确实有室内植物，那将就像角落里的一株雕塑般的室内植物，
like not surrounded by any other plow's plants, and then also like placed as almost a beacon in a room, right? One of the few decorations that the space could echo off of. So each one has a spatial impact, whereas in the Victorian home it's, they're all mushed together into a jungle-like, ensemble, if you like. So now it's using individual plants
就像不被任何其他室内植物包围一样，然后也被放置得几乎像房间里的灯塔一样，对吧？空间可以与之呼应的为数不多的装饰之一。因此，每一个都有空间影响，而在维多利亚时代，它是，它们全都被塞进了一个像丛林一样的合奏中，如果你愿意的话。所以现在它在以更具战略意义的方式使用
in much more strategic ways. Popular house plants during this period included the famously sculptural monstera deliciosa, the rubber plant with its thick shiny leaves, and perhaps the most modernist plant of all, the cactus. Absolutely, because it's small, sculptural, and you would find rows of cacti in one shelf, say,
单个植物。这一时期流行的室内植物包括著名的雕塑般的龟背竹、有着厚厚闪亮叶子的橡皮树，以及也许是最现代主义的植物——仙人掌。绝对是这样，因为它是小型、雕塑感的，你会在一个架子上找到一排排的仙人掌，比方说，
and that would be all you'd find of plant life in a modernist interior. But if modernism was a relative em in our relationship with indoor plants, by the 1960s and 70s, homes were once again washed in green. Well, the 70s was a period of great opulence of plants again in interiors. That was the era of the Mac from a hanging basket.
而这将会是你在现代主义室内设计中找到的全部植物生命。但如果现代主义是我们与室内植物关系的相对减弱，到了20世纪60和70年代，住宅再次被绿色洗刷。好吧，70年代是室内植物再次极度富裕的时期。那是用macrame吊篮的时代。
I'm old enough to remember them. And bringing jungle-like interiors back in again. And this wave in the 70s corresponded with a shift in interior design. A move away from the stark minimalism of the modern period and towards a looser style. The angular sofa gave way to the beanback chair and houseplants once again, proliferated.
我老得足以记住它们。并再次将类似丛林的室内装潢带回来。70年代的这股浪潮与室内设计观念的转变相对应。从现代时期的严峻极简主义转向更宽松的风格。棱角分明的沙发让位给懒人沙发，室内植物再次激增。
So you have the trailing spider plant in a macrame hanger, or just houseplants just hanging out in a much more maximalist style that really did. I think it a lot of ways resembled the Victorian era. Like the Victorian era, the houseplant wave of the 60s and 70s was driven in part by a feeling that people had lost touch with nature. This was the dawn of the modern environmental movement and the back-to-land movement. People were longing to reconnect with the natural world.
所以你有挂在macrame吊篮里的垂吊吊兰，或者只是室内植物闲晃在一种更具极繁主义风格的装饰中，确实如此。我认为它在很多方面类似于维多利亚时代。就像维多利亚时代一样，60和70年代的室内植物浪潮部分是由人们觉得与自然失去联系的感觉所驱动的。这是现代环保运动和回归土地运动的黎明。人们渴望重新与自然世界建立联系。
And the concept of biofilia comes along, which basically means that there's some sort of deep spiritual almost link between us and plants, because although we may not have lived within nature for two or three generations, we still have the memory of it, and that it can be evoked by surrounding ourselves with plants. In 1973, the Secret Life of Plants was published. The book argued that plants were capable of thought and feeling. The authors relied on a lot of new AG pseudoscience, but they were tapping into the plant worshipping zeitgeist.
然后生物亲缘的概念出现了，这基本上意味着我们和植物之间存在着某种深厚的精神联系，因为虽然我们可能没有在自然中生活两三代人，但我们仍然有它的记忆，并且可以通过用植物环绕自己来唤起它。1973年，《植物的秘密生命》出版了。这本书认为植物具有思考和感受的能力。作者依赖了许多新时代伪科学，但他们正在挖掘崇拜植物的时代精神。
But the intensity of people's love for plants eventually became the object of ridicule, and noticed a wave of houseplant media coverage during this decade, including three cover stories in New York magazine. And there's this picture in one of them, it's called the Secrets of the Plant People. And the picture on the cover is of people, of different silhouettes of people, and each of them has like a plant for a face, like the plant has overtaken their minds. And the subjects here was that people's love of houseplants was going too far. They were obsessives.
但人们对植物的热爱最终成为了嘲笑的对象，并注意到这十年中关于室内植物的媒体报道浪潮，包括《纽约》杂志上的三篇封面故事。其中一篇上面有一张照片，叫做《植物人的秘密》。封面上的照片是人，不同人的剪影，每个人都像植物一样长着一张脸，就像植物接管了他们的思想一样。这里的主题是人们对室内植物的热爱走得太远了。他们是痴迷者。
Then all of the photos, including the one on the cover, depict people who seem to have succumbed to a sort of plant mania. So these spaces in New York and the burrows that are just filled with plants, like a guy whose attic is all orchids, or a guy whose entire apartment is begonias, Nikolam, a begonim maniac. And the art direction there is for you to think like, these people are crazy. This is what you don't want to be. The message here was that it was cool to be a person who had plants, but you didn't
然后所有的照片，包括封面上的那张，都描绘了似乎屈服于某种植物狂热的人们。所以纽约和行政区的这些空间到处都是植物，比如一个阁楼上全是兰花的家伙，或者一个整个公寓都是秋海棠的家伙，尼科兰，一个秋海棠狂人。那里的艺术指导是让你觉得，这些人疯了。这就是你不想成为的样子。这里的消息是，成为一个拥有植物的人是很酷的，但你不想
want to go too far. You didn't want to be a plant person. In the end, the hippie houseplant movement was fairly short-lived. In her book, Apotted History, the historian Catherine Horwood writes that, by the end of the 20th century, houseplants had become, quote, just another burden. Yet one more thing to look after once work was finished, the house cleaned, the dog fed, and the children put to bed.
走得太远。你不想成为一个植物人。最后，嬉皮士室内植物运动是相当短命的。历史学家凯瑟琳·霍伍德在她的书《盆栽历史》中写道，到20世纪末，室内植物已经成为，引用的话，“只是另一个负担”。下班后、打扫完房子、喂了狗、把孩子哄上床后，又多了一件要照料的事情。
But as we learned, our love of houseplants, ebbs and flows, and that brings us to our current wave, which Anne argues began around 2010. That's when I remember seeing more and more succulents and houseplants just generally for sale in places like Target. A lot of different factors contributed to our contemporary houseplant boom. Many young people are living in small apartments and cities without a lot of outdoor space, and houseplants are an alternative to gardening. They've also just become cheaper and more widely available. You can buy them at boutique
但正如我们所了解到的，我们对室内植物的热爱起起落落，这把我们带到了我们当前的浪潮，安妮认为这始于2010年前后。那就是我记得在塔吉特这样的地方看到越来越多的多肉植物和室内植物通常在出售的时候。许多不同的因素促成了我们当代室内植物的热潮。许多年轻人住在没有太多户外空间的城市的小公寓里，室内植物是园艺的替代品。它们也变得更便宜、更容易买到。你可以在精品
plant shops or in the checkout line at Urban Outfitters along with a tote bag that says hashtag succulent squad, or on websites like the sill, which will ship a plant right to your house. And there are plants swaps where collectors meet up to trade cuttings of their favorite varieties. And then of course, there is Instagram, which has enabled people to document their collections and share plant care strategies on a massive scale. The popularity of houseplants on social media has supercharged the houseplant trend cycle. Varieties go in and out of fashion like sneakers, And some people spend hundreds or even thousands of dollars
植物店购买它们，或者在 Urban Outfitters 的结账排队处购买，连同印有“#多肉小队”字样的手提袋，或者在像 The Sill 这样的网站上购买，它们会直接把植物运到你家。还有植物交换活动，收藏家们聚在一起交易他们最喜欢的品种的插条。然后当然还有 Instagram，它使人们能够大规模地记录他们的收藏并分享植物照料策略。社交媒体上室内植物的流行使室内植物的趋势周期超增压。品种像运动鞋一样进出时尚圈，有些人花数百甚至数千美元
at Rare Houseplant auctions. So I think the first trend that we are going to be seeing going into 2022 is variegated and theorem. Okay, the next one is the variegated allocation. As you can see from the picture, they are stunning. Around 2016, the It house plant was Pilea pepperon miyoi-dies, or the Chinese money plant, which grows naturally in Yunnan. When Pilea first got popular on Instagram, it was expensive and hard to find. People in the US were paying over $50 for a tiny little one. But then, the industrial nursery has just started growing more of it,
在珍稀室内植物拍卖会上。所以我想我们将在2022年看到的第一大趋势是锦斑天南星。好的，下一个是锦斑海芋。正如你从图片中看到的，它们非常惊艳。2016年前后，最火的室内植物是镜面草，或中国钱财草，它原产于云南。当镜面草最初在 Instagram 上走红时，它很昂贵且很难找到。美国的民众花50多美元买一个小小的植物。但是后来，工业苗圃开始种植更多，
and the prices dropped, and today Pilea is everywhere. a tiny little one. But then, the industrial nursery has just started growing more of it, and the prices dropped, and today, Pylea is everywhere. You can get a small one for $5-10 at just about any plant store you walk into. The growth in the house plant industry has made collecting more affordable and accessible, but it also comes with costs. Rare plant species are sometimes harvested illegally from the wild and sold on eBay and Facebook. And when house plants get popular, they become mass-produced commodities. It takes a lot of water to grow them and plastic
价格下降了，今天镜面草无处不在。一个小小的。但是后来，工业苗圃开始种植更多，价格下降了，今天，镜面草无处不在。你走进的几乎任何一家植物店都可以花5-10美元买到一个小的。室内植物产业的增长使收藏变得更加实惠和普及，但也伴随着代价。珍稀植物品种有时被从野外非法采集并在 eBay 和 Facebook 上出售。当室内植物变得流行时，它们就成了批量生产的商品。种植它们需要大量的水，塑料
to keep them in pots and fossil fuels to ship them around the world, also you can have the next trendy plant as quickly and cheaply as possible. Anne Helen Peterson says that on its surface, this Instagram-driven houseplant mania can feel like something totally new, like a clean break from the past. But she also sees echoes of the different eras of houseplant history in our current moment.
用来把它们放在花盆里，化石燃料把它们运往世界各地，这样你也可以尽可能快地、尽可能便宜地拥有下一个时髦的植物。安妮·海伦·彼得森说，表面上看，这种由 Instagram 驱动的室内植物狂热感觉像是一种全新的东西，就像与过去的彻底决裂。但她也在我们当前的时刻看到了室内植物历史不同时代的回响。
Yeah, I think that this current moment really began with a more modernist understanding, especially with the embrace of the succulent. Like the succulent is a very modernist style. This was happening at the same time as the mid-century modern furniture Renaissance. And so you might have one or two succulents that would look great next to your knockoff eames chair. But something interesting has happened over the course of, I would say, the last 10, 12 years.
是的，我认为当前的这个时刻确实始于一种更现代主义的理解，特别是对多肉植物的拥抱。就像多肉植物是一种非常现代主义的风格。这发生在世纪中期现代家具复兴的同一时期。所以你可能会有一两盆多肉植物，在你的仿冒伊姆斯椅旁看起来很棒。但我要说的是，在过去10、12年的时间里，发生了一件有趣的事情。
I think that if you started with a single plant, because you were like, that looks good. You know, I can handle a single plant. It looked good on Instagram. Those people have kind of caught the fever. And I'm like, oh, now I have 15 plants. Is this too many plants? And pretty soon, your minimalist mid-century modern interior
我认为，如果你从一株植物开始，因为你觉得，这看起来不错。你知道，我能应付一株植物。它在 Instagram 上看起来很好。那些人有点感染了这种狂热。我想，哦，现在我有15盆植物了。植物太多了吗？不久之后，你的极简主义世纪中期现代室内设计
starts to look like a Victorian drawing room, or the downtown apartment of a crazed Bagonia maniac. Which is what I have now. So instead of having, you know, I have some pieces that are structural parts of the decor and then a lot more that are just spreading, kind of like it's like an oozing virus. It's like more plants in as many directions as possible. And told me that she currently has like 40 houseplants, which I think is a lot.
开始看起来像维多利亚时代的会客室，或者一个疯狂的秋海棠狂人的市中心公寓。这就是我现在的情况。所以不是说我有，你知道的，我有一些作为装饰结构部分的单品，然后还有更多只是在蔓延，有点像它就像一种渗出的病毒。就像在尽可能多的方向上有更多的植物。并告诉我她目前大约有40盆室内植物，我认为这很多。
I've got like 11 and that feels like a lot, but I wanted to talk to someone who is more obsessed than either of us, someone who has made houseplants a central part of his identity. Oh, hello. I'll, uh, what are you in? Okay, thanks so much. Mikhail Bucho lives with his partner, Paul,
我有大约11盆，这感觉已经很多了，但我想和比我们任何一个都更痴迷的人谈谈，一个把室内植物作为其身份核心部分的人。哦，你好。我会，呃，你穿什么？好的，非常感谢。米哈伊尔·布乔和他的伴侣保罗住在一起，
and a cute little apartment in Oakland. When they first moved in, Mikhail really wanted to get a cat, but Paul was allergic. Once we can't get the cat, I was like, okay, let's do something else. And so he went out and got his very first house plan. It was a fight guess that he got from Trader Joe's.
和奥克兰的一个可爱的小公寓。当他们刚搬进来时，米哈伊尔真的很想养只猫，但保罗过敏。既然我们不能养猫，我就想，好吧，让我们做点别的。于是他出去拿了他第一盆室内植物。这是一株从 Trader Joe's 买来的琴叶榕。
He loved it. And so he got another plant this time, Oman Stera, then another and pretty soon he was hooked. This has just like became like a passion on the side. So it just grew from a single fight us to like now a hundred plus of plants indoors and in the balcony. So yeah a lot of plants And those plants have a lot of fans Mikhail has 25,000 Instagram followers who watch him water fertilize and take care of his plant babies This signature move is that he dances with his plants using stop motion.
他很喜欢它。所以他得到了另一株植物，这次是一株龟背竹，然后是另一株，很快他就上瘾了。这就像变成了一种副业激情。所以它从一株琴叶榕发展到现在的室内和阳台上一百多株植物。所以是的，很多植物。而那些植物有很多粉丝，米哈伊尔在 Instagram 上拥有25,000名粉丝，他们看他浇水、施肥和照顾他的植物宝宝们。他的招牌动作是用定格动画和他的植物一起跳舞。
I rotate them like quarter by quarter until they do a full twist, and then through power of edit, you could make them dance. To what song? Um, it depends. There's the fluoride spinning head right around and around. I'm spinning my head right, right, right, right, right. When you go down, when you go down, down. It's like a house with my bag of house.
我把它们旋转，一圈一圈地转，直到它们完成一个完整的转圈，然后通过剪辑的力量，你可以让它们跳舞。什么歌？嗯，这取决于。这里有氟利昂旋转的头转啊转。我把我的头转得对，对，对，对，对。当你倒下时，当你倒下，倒下。就像一栋房子，带着我的house包。
On Instagram, Maca house apartment feels like a greenhouse club. But in person, it's quiet and peaceful. Yeah. I usually, in the morning, I light an incense and just like look into the window and just adore the plants. What do you like about them or like what emotions do they give you? Oh gosh, it reminds me of my childhood growing up in the Philippines. growing up in the Philippines. I have a little farm so a little like growing up in a little country so it's fun to like have plants around you again kind of like reminds me of my childhood memories. Some of MacIllas plants are actually
在 Instagram 上，Maca house 公寓感觉像是一个温室俱乐部。但在现实中，它是安静祥和的。是的。我通常在早上点一根香，然后看着窗户，只是崇拜这些植物。你喜欢它们的什么或者它们给你什么情感？哦天哪，这让我想起了我在菲律宾长大的童年。在菲律宾长大。我有一个小农场，所以有点像在小乡村长大，所以在你身边再次有植物很有趣，有点让我想起我的童年记忆。米哈伊尔的一些植物实际上是
needed to the Philippines. He says that when he facetimes with his grandma she'll recognize plants inside of his apartment. So I collected some of them just to like, honor my country like this biggest allocation I have. That is from our province of Beekle, which is in the east side of the Philippines. So I collect like small things that reminds me of home. Mikael says that knowing a house plant's context in the wild is important to him as a collector.
菲律宾本土的。他说，当他和他的奶奶进行视频通话时，她会认出他公寓里的植物。所以我收集了其中一些只是为了，向我的国家致敬，就像我拥有的这个最大的海芋一样。那是来自我们比科尔省的，它在菲律宾的东侧。所以我收集了一些让我想起家的小东西。米哈伊尔说，作为一个收藏家，了解室内植物在野外的背景对很重要。
It can help him understand what the plant needs and how to take care of it. But it also reminds him of the long journey that that plant took to end up in his apartment. Since the early days of European colonization houseplants have become commodity sold on a global marketplace. And at this point, there's a certain placelessness to them. Today, you might encounter the same houseplant at a coffee shop in Tokyo, or a hotel in Mexico City, or more likely on Instagram. And then you can go online and order that same plant for yourself, and it will appear on your doorstep in a couple of days. Buying house plants has gotten so easy that you can lose track of the fact
这可以帮助他了解植物需要什么以及如何照顾它。但这也让他想起这株植物为了最终进入他的公寓而进行的漫长旅程。自欧洲殖民统治早期以来，室内植物已成为全球市场上出售的商品。在这一点上，它们具有某种无地方感。今天，你可能会在东京的一家咖啡馆、墨西哥城的一家酒店，或者更有可能在 Instagram 上遇到同样的室内植物。然后你可以上网为自己订购同一株植物，它会在几天内出现在你的门廊上。购买室内植物变得如此简单，以至于你可能会忽略这样一个事实：
that these objects of interior design are also living organisms from a particular place, and each one has a history. After the break, what's better for your plants? Flow righte or buck cantadas. Stay with us. So we're back with our engineer, Martín González. Hey, Martín. Hey, everyone, what's up?
这些室内设计的物品也是来自特定地方的生物，每一个都有自己的历史。休息之后，什么对你的植物更好？流畅节奏还是巴赫清唱剧。请继续收听。所以我们回到了我们的工程师马丁·加萨雷斯。嘿，马丁。嘿，大家好，怎么了？
And we're here to talk about plants and music. I wanted to start off by playing you some of my favorite plant-related music. This amazing record called Plantasia by Mork Garcin. It's from 1976, right in the middle of the second big houseplant boom and it came free with purchases at Mother Earth plant store in Los Angeles. I mean, I would definitely expect that coming from a place called Mother Earth, that kind of spacey new AG psychedelic, you know, kind of music, but I guess it's not necessarily what I'd associate with plants. Totally. Like, everyone's heard that classical music is supposed to help plants grow,
我们在这里讨论植物和音乐。我想先播放一些我最喜欢的与植物相关的音乐。莫克·加尔辛一张名为《Plantasia》的神奇唱片。它来自1976年，正值第二大室内植物热潮的中间，它是在洛杉矶的“大地母亲”植物店购买商品时免费赠送的。我的意思是，我绝对期望来自一个叫“大地母亲”的地方，那种太空般的新时代迷幻，你知道的，那种音乐，但我想这不一定是我会与植物联系在一起的音乐。完全是。就像，每个人都听说过古典音乐应该能帮助植物生长，
and it feels kind of intuitively true. Right. You know, it's music that smart people listen to, so it's got to be like scientifically superior. Right. Sure. So I looked into it to see if it was a real thing. And the first person to make this claim was an Indian scientist in the early 1900s named Jagdish Chandra Bose. He needs a major discoveries in how electricity works in plants and measured how they reacted to stimulus. But he took those discoveries into some pretty wild territory. He claimed that plants actually have thoughts and feelings, and of course musical preferences. But like turn of the 20th century is way earlier than I thought for that kind of like, you know,
这感觉在直觉上是真的。对。你知道的，那是聪明人听的音乐，所以它一定在科学上更优越。对。当然。所以我查了一下，看它是否是一件真实的事情。第一个提出这个主张的人是20世纪初的一位印度科学家，名叫贾格迪什·钱德拉·博斯。他在植物电力的工作方式上做出了重大发现，并测量了它们对刺激的反应。但他把这些发现带到了一些非常疯狂的领域。他声称植物实际上有思想和感受，当然还有音乐偏好。但这就像20世纪初，比我想象的这种，你知道的，
woo-woo notion. Yeah, it was still a fringy idea for most of the 20th century until the secret life of plants, which we referenced in the main story. It was a book that came out in 1973 and adapted a few years later into a movie. ["Movey"]
无稽之谈的概念要早得多。是的，在20世纪的大部分时间里，它仍然是一个边缘观点，直到我们在主要故事中提到的《植物的秘密生命》。这是一本在1973年出版并在几年后改编成电影的书。["电影"]
It's really more of a vibe than a documentary. There's long stretches of time lapse, photography of plants growing, and a beautiful Stevie Wonder soundtrack. Mainly though, it's full of pseudo-scientific experiments and anecdotal evidence to support some, shall we say, dubious claims about plant consciousness. For example, it heavily features the work of Cleve Baxter. Before studying plants, he was a CIA interrogator and one of the foremost polygraph experts in his day.
与其说它是纪录片，不如说它是一种氛围。有很长时间的植物生长延时摄影，以及精彩的史蒂夫·旺达配乐。不过，最主要的是，它充满了伪科学实验和轶事证据，用以支持一些，我们姑且这么说吧，关于植物意识的可疑主张。例如，它大量展示了克利夫·巴克斯特的工作。在研究植物之前，他是中情局审讯员，也是他那个时代最重要的测谎专家之一。
He was working late one night and wondered what kind of lie detector readings his office plant would give. He watered it and... It went into sort of the wild excitation very similar to the first part of a human taking a polygraph test. That made him curious about how a plant might react to a threat, and he decided he would light one of its leaves on fire. He didn't have any matches and was thinking about going to the other room to grab some. But before you even got up, something unexpected happened.
一天深夜，他正在工作，想知道他的办公室植物会给出什么样的测谎仪读数。他给它浇了水，然后……它进入了一种狂野的兴奋状态，非常类似于人类接受测谎仪测试的第一部分。这让他对植物可能对威胁做出何种反应产生了好气，他决定点燃它的一片叶子。他没有任何火柴，正想着去另一个房间拿一些。但就在你甚至没有站起来之前，意想不到的事情发生了。
The tracing just went right off the top of the page. And the only thing that occurred at that time, no lighting of a match, nothing else, nearly the imagery of fire. Wait, so he thought that the plant could read his mind thinking about fire? Yeah, that is exactly what he's saying. The plants have ESP, and he goes on to claim that plants get distressed at the harm of any living being, which he tries to prove by killing a bunch of shrimp in front of plants to see if they get upset. At some undetermined moment chosen by a randomizer, these brine shrimp will fall to their deaths in boiling water.
描迹直接冲出了纸张的顶部。当时发生的事情只有这些，没有点燃火柴，也没有别的，几乎全是对火的想象。等等，所以他以为植物能读懂他关于火的心思？是的，他说的就是这个。植物有超感官知觉，他接着声称，植物会在任何生物受到伤害时感到痛苦，他试图通过在植物面前杀死一堆虾来证明这一点，看看它们是否会难过。在由随机发生器选择的某个不确定时刻，这些卤虫将落入沸水中死亡。
This is demented. Yeah, he also has a researcher commit plant murder by ripping up one plant in front of another one. In some mysterious way, the plant which is attached to the instrument is able to feel the mutilation of its comrades. Hours later, the technicians are asked to return to the scene of the crime. The evidence is clear.
这太疯狂了。是的，他还让一名研究人员在另一株植物面前拔掉一株植物，从而实施了“植物谋杀”。通过某种神秘的方式，连接在仪器上的植物能够感受到其同伴遭受的摧残。几小时后，技术人员被要求返回犯罪现场。证据很明显。
The remaining plant has correctly identified the assailant. Wow. So what they're saying is, it's like, there could be a plant in a room that's seen of a crime, like a murk can happen. And the plant would be a witness to it and could pinpoint who did the murder. That's a stunning. I am surprised I haven't seen that on law and order at this point.
剩下的那株植物已经正确指认了凶手。哇。所以他们说的是，这就好像，房间里可能有一株植物目击了犯罪现场，比如可能会发生谋杀案。植物可以成为目击者，并能指出是谁杀了人。这太惊人了。我很惊讶我到现在还没在《法律与秩序》里看到过这个。
Yeah, and like, you know, as soon as you hear, you go, that's a little too far. And this is kind of a recurring theme. The results of the experiments sound too good to be true, and they end up being difficult or impossible to replicate. There's frequently methodology issues and experimenter bias. It's really easy to selectively interpret this polygraph data to fit whatever theory you've cooked up. So, going back to the idea that classical music helps plants grow. Around the same time as Secret Life of Plants, this pianist named Dorothy Ritalic conducted these experiments
是的，而且就像，你知道的，你一听到就会觉得，这有点太离谱了。这算是一个反复出现的主题。实验结果听起来好得令人难以置信，但最终却很难甚至无法复制。这其中经常存在方法论问题和实验者偏见。人们很容易选择性地解释这些多谱勒测谎数据，以符合你编造的任何理论。所以，回到古典音乐有助于植物生长的观点。大约在《植物的秘密生命》出版的同时，一位名叫多萝西·里塔利克的钢琴家进行了这些实验
about plants and music. Now, it's important to note, she was't a botanist, just an undergrads music student fulfilling a biology requirement. But her experiments got tons of media coverage because they were very attention-grabby. For example, here's a clip from a 1977 episode of Insertreve hosted by none other than Leonard Nimoy. Mrs. Ritalic theorized that in subtle ways, plants might share her sensitivity to sound. Harsh music had always bothered Mrs. Ritalic. Could it be that plants also preferred one sound to another?
关于植物和音乐。现在需要注意的是，她不是植物学，只是一个为了完成生物学要求的本科音乐专业学生。但她的实验获得了大量的媒体报道，因为它们非常吸引眼球。例如，这是1977年播出的节目《插入重现》中的一个片段，由伦纳德·尼莫伊主持。里塔利克夫人推测，植物可能会以微妙的方式分享她对声音的敏感。刺耳的音乐一直困扰着里塔利克夫人。难道植物也更喜欢某种声音而不是另一种吗？
She set up an experiment with two groups of plants in separate soundproof chambers. Semiclassical music was played into one. Hard rock into the other. of plants in separate soundproof chambers. And in a coincidence no one could have guessed guessed the music that helps plants grow just so happens to be the kind of music that she likes. What a shock. And like the dead giveaways that in her book about these says, she says that the withered plants reminded her of the burnouts at rock festivals and she also volunteers to use her research in antidrug
她用两个隔音室里的两组植物做了一个实验。其中一个播放半古典音乐。另一个播放硬摇滚。在隔音室里有两组植物。巧合的是，谁也猜不到，帮助植物生长的音乐，恰好是她喜欢的音乐。真是太令人震惊了。正如她在关于这的书中所暗示的，她直言不讳地说，枯萎的植物让她想起摇滚音乐节上的垮掉派，她还自愿将自己的研究用于反毒品
PSAs. Oh my goodness, okay. Now there is plenty of evidence that plans do react to sound. Experiments have proven that they'll grow towards a speaker that's playing the sound of running water, or release toxins when they hear the sound of a caterpillar chomping on the leaves. But whenever other researchers have tried to replicate this kind of music experiment, though, generally, what they found is that plants don't have any preference for a specific kind
公益广告。噢天哪，好吧。现在有大量的证据表明，植物确实对声音有反应。实验证明它们会朝着播放流水声的扬声器生长，或者在听到毛毛虫啃食叶子的声音时释放毒素。然而，每当其他研究人员试图重复这种音乐实验时，他们通常发现植物对特定种类的音乐没有任何偏好。
of music. What they like is moving air, as opposed to stagnant air, so it's just the waves of the sound rather than the content of it. And in fact, when mythbusters tried it out, their heavy metal plants outperform the classical music ones. That's interesting. So we've been talking a lot about what sounds plants like, but what about the sounds plants can make? So for me, the coolest part of Secret Life of Plants is this artist named John Lichten,
它们喜欢的是流动的空气，而不是停滞的空气，所以起作用的是声音的波形而不是内容。事实上，当“流言终结者”节目尝试这样做时，听重金属音乐的植物表现甚至超过了听古典音乐的植物。这很有趣。所以我们一直在讨论植物喜欢什么声音，但植物能发出什么声音呢？对我和说，最酷的部分《植物的秘密生命》是一个叫约翰·里希滕的艺术家，
who did a project where he hooked plants up to synthesizers. And along the same lines, I've got this device called a plant wave. It turns your house plants into little Brian E. Nose. Yeah. So how does that end up working? It's actually pretty similar to the method that cleave backstriused. Basically, you attach electrical sensors to your plant and it reads the fluctuating voltages. But instead of using that data to fit cookie theories, the plan wave maps it onto soothing
他做了一个项目，把植物连接到合成器上。同样，我也有一个叫“植物波”的设备。它能把你的室内植物变成小布赖恩·伊诺。是的。那它是怎么运作的呢？其实和克里夫·巴克斯特使用的方法挺像的。基本上，你把电子传感器连接到植物上，它就能读取波动的电压。但是，植物波并没有用这些数据去迎合那些稀奇古怪的理论，而是将其转化为舒缓的
flutes and tinkles and bloops. And as the plant photosynthesizes, the sound it produces changes over time. So I hooked it up to my aloe and I let it get just a little drier than usually you would. And it was just only putting out these couple sparse, lonely notes. I watered it and I came back 12 hours later and I heard all these rich harmonies. I heard all these rich harmonies. Oh, that's so cool. So when Emmett interviewed Mikael for this story, we also brought along a plant wave and
长笛声、叮咚声和嘟嘟声。随着植物进行光合作用，它产生的声音也会随之改变。所以我把它连上了我的芦荟，让它比平时稍微干了一点。它只发出寥寥几个稀疏、孤单的音符。我给它浇了水，12个小时后回来，就听到了所有这些丰富的和声。我听到了所有这些丰富的和声。噢，太酷了。所以当埃姆特为这个故事采访迈克尔时，我们也带上了植物波，并
recorded his monstera to see what it would sound like. And we thought it sounded so cool that we actually ended up using it in the story to score the part about 1970s plant culture. Wow. So did you try other plants beside the Monstera? I mean, do different plants sound different? Well, you know, it's kind of the anthropomorphic view where it's not like a palm tree sounds like a surf guitar and a cactus sounds like mariachi.
录下了他的龟背竹的声音，看看它听起来会怎么样。我们觉得这听起来太酷了，最后甚至把它用在故事里，作为描述20世纪70年代植物文化的配乐。哇。所以除了龟背竹，你还尝试了其他植物吗？我是说，不同的植物听起来会不同吗？嗯，你知道，这有点像拟人化的观点，并不是说棕榈树听起来像冲浪吉他，而仙人掌听起来像墨西哥乐队。
If only. It's really more a palm tree sounds like a surf guitar and a cactus sounds like mariachi. If only. It's really more of a collaboration. You choose the sound and scale and the plant picks the notes and the rhythms. I see. And what I like about this device is that in the marketing, they go out of their way to not make any wild scientific claims.
要真是那样就好了。实际上这更像是一种合作。你选择声音和音阶，然后由植物来挑选音符和节奏。我明白了。我喜欢这个设备的地方在于，在营销中，他们刻意不去做出任何离谱的科学断言。
They say it's just a pleasing way to create music together with your plants and help you feel closer to them. It's kind of like Mikael dancing with his plants to make TikToks. Spending more time with them makes you better tuned into their needs. And that'll help them grow much more than blasting violin concertos at them. Right, right. You're not inflicting your musical tastes on them and insisting that it makes them better plants. And in the end, the music that we made together came out closer to plantasia than it did to Bach.
他们说这只是一种与植物一起创造音乐的令人愉快的方式，能帮你感觉离它们更近一些。这有点像迈克尔和他的植物一起跳舞来拍抖音。花更多时间陪伴它们能让你更敏锐地了解它们的需求。这会比对着它们狂放小提琴协奏曲更能帮助它们生长。对，对。你没有把自己的音乐品味强加给它们，并坚称这能让它们成为更好的植物。最后，我们一起创作的音乐听起来更接近《植物园》而不是巴赫。
Right. So, but I really like the plant music that you made. So let's play some more of that and we'll just like do the credits over that. Okay, yeah. So this is an oregano plant that I grew from a clipping I got from my dad. 99% of visible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald and Anne Helen Peterson, mixed in tech production by Martin Gonzales, music by a director of sound Swan Rial with assistance from Mikael's Monstera and Martins, Allo and Oregano. Tulenihal is the executive producer, Kirk Cole's state is our digital writer.
对。所以，但我真的很喜欢你做的植物音乐。所以让我们多放一些，我们就在那上面念制作名单。好的，是的。这是一株牛至植物，是我从我爸那拿的一根枝条培育出来的。本周99%可见是由埃姆特·菲茨杰拉德和安·海伦·彼得森制作的，混音和技术制作由马丁·冈萨雷斯完成，音乐由声音总监天鹅里阿尔创作，并得到了迈克尔的龟背竹以及马丁的芦荟和牛至的协助。图利内哈尔是执行制片人，柯克·科尔斯泰特是我们的数字撰稿人。
The rest of the team includes Vivian Leigh, Chris Baroubaix, Christopher Johnson, Lashmadan, Sophia Klatsker, Jason De Leon, Joe Rosenberg, Intern, Sarah Bake, and me Roman Mars. Big thanks this week to Anne Helen Peterson. Today's episode was inspired by Anne's houseplant essay on her sub-stack Culture Study. It's a great read and you should totally check it out. Also Penny Spark's book about houseplant history is called Nature Inside. It's also great. And thank you to Joe Patatucci and Data Garden for sending us a plant wave so that our plants could make sounds.
团队其他成员包括维维安·李、克里斯·巴鲁贝、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉什马丹、索菲亚·克拉茨克、杰森·德莱昂、乔·罗森伯格、实习生莎拉·贝克，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。本周要特别感谢安·海伦·彼得森。今天的节目灵感来自安在她Substack专栏《文化研究》上发表的关于室内植物的文章。这是一篇很棒的读物，你绝对应该去看看。另外，佩妮·斯帕克斯关于室内植物历史的书叫《自然内在》。它也很棒。感谢乔·帕塔图奇和数据花园给我们送来植物波，让我们的植物也能发出声音。
You can find links to all those things on our website. 99% of visible is part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and write it too. You can find links to others to your shows I love,
你可以在我们的网站上找到所有这些东西的链接。99%可见是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分。现在总部位于向北六个街区的潘多拉大楼。位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市住宅区。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并加入关于节目的讨论。你可以在推特上@我罗曼·马尔斯，以及本节目@99PI org。我们也在Instagram和Reddit上。你可以找到其他你喜欢的节目的链接，
as well as every past episode of 99PI. at 99PI.org. Dr. Hashimoto, managing director and chief of research for the Fuji electronic industries, has constructed special instruments which translate the electrical output of plants into to a cactus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及99PI的每一期往期节目，网址是99PI.org。桥本博士是富士电子工业公司的常务董事兼研究主管，他制造了特殊的仪器，将植物的电输出转化为仙人掌。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。